for the first time ever first year  associates at new york law firms that is  people who just graduated from law  school  are going to start out with a salary of  200 000  or more here's how this works there are  some fancy law firms in new york it used  to be cravath now it tends to be milbank  tweet that  set the salary that lots of other law  firms follow and this time for the first  year ever  milbank tweed is offering first year  associates 200 thousand dollars plus  bonus fifth year associates are going to  make 300 000  and well that sounds like a lot of money  and it is a lot of money remember that  number one they're gonna have to live in  new york which is incredibly expensive  and number two  they're probably have to bill at least 2  400 hours which means  they're probably going to be working at  least 3 000 hours a year  which means about 60 hours a week so yes  these are white collar jobs but this is  hard work with very long hours